so again what is Final Fantasy 16
um well Final Fantasy 16 is the newest
number title in the uh Final Fantasy
series a stories franchise with over 35
years of History Generations
all right and so what is it that makes
this Final Fantasy series unique
um is that however despite the fact that
the titles are numbered each one is
independent from the others it features
its own story its own characters its own
systems and its own feel and Final
Fantasy 16 is no different in that sense
um and so it should be just as
accessible to a newcomer to the
franchise as it is to a longtime fan
players will not need to play any of the
games before this to fully enjoy Final
Fantasy 16 but of course it's okay if
you do
so one thing that we've talked about
repeatedly is how we built this game on
four pillars
[Music]
so first and foremost of those pillars
is Story series
so with Final Fantasy 16 um it's always
been our aim to bring back the series to
its high fantasy Roots exploring these
con complex themes such as Justice and
values while weaving a deep um and
sweeping narrative complete with
politics conflict and Intrigue we wanted
to create something that would not only
resonate with a younger generation of
players just stepping out on their own
but also with older players like me I'm
going to be 50 years old this year and
we already know how harsh the real world
can be
foreign
all right while our main focus of Final
Fantasy 16 is and the narrative is fixed
upon Clive rossfield as he seeks
Vengeance for the loss of his nation and
his family our game features a vast
ensemble cast of compelling characters
each unique in their own backgrounds and
motivations and their stories players
will watch unfold around clives in this
veritable Clash of Wills master
and of course we cannot forget Graphics
our team has worked very hard to create
this unparalleled visual experience as
only Power possible with the power of
the PlayStation 5.
you your skelex I'm Square Enix
oh it's okay
we love you Sony the power of the
PlayStation 5.
and finally and possibly most
importantly
um is our battle systems
and so our dedication has been to create
this exciting combat system that for the
first time in this series
um introduces full real-time action
combat
guys
players will get
um to experience this thrilling summon
versus summon battles which put Clive in
control uh of an icon of his own to
carry out battles on a massive scale um
the final fantasy series has long been
described as a cinematic experience but
now we can truly liken this to actually
playing a Hollywood action Blockbusters
all right the talk is cheap so we've
prepared a short video of captured
in-game footage showcasing the four
pillars let's start
I only stand here today because of
Joshua 13 years I've waited for this
chance
I slept in the filth junk from a gutter
killed more men that I can count
ready my lady
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
mother mother video
and that is not uh the only video we're
going to be showing you we have uh many
more videos we showed you today so
please look forward to them as well
um
and everything you saw here this is not
pre-rendered this is all running in real
time in engine it is a variable roller
coaster ride of a game
foreign
is made from uh five different nations
and one neutral steady state uh
so across the realm can be found the
mother crystals these towering
Wellsprings of life and Magic around
which civilization civilization thrives
one might think of these
um as oil fields
and these oil fields these mother
crystals are where the realm gains its
energy that powers their everyday lives
The Ether which can be compared to uh
oil and so this resource however proves
to be finite and because of that This
Bitter struggle arises amongst the
Nations over control of what little
remains
and that brings us into the current Age
of War and strife
foreign
and so we're going to be showing some of
the areas that are available for
exploration in Final Fantasy 16 with
this short walk through video let's
begin
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Music]
is a
and again what we just showed you
um is these are not cut scenes these are
all areas that Clive will be able to go
to and explore and have Dallas
[Music]
and again we hope you have fun exploring
the world and hope you look forward to
it
is
all right next we'd like to shift Focus
um to our characters specifically the
dominant these wardens of the elements
and the keepers of the icons that play
such a central role in our narrative
is
but what are the icons um the icon is
the Final Fantasy 16 for what fans of
the series will known as the summons
these mythical giant magical beasts of
Legend capable of taking out entire
nations if not kept in check
um in Final Fantasy 16 their size ranges
from 60 feet to over 350 feet tall
foreign
s are not summoned um but it is the
dominance who literally become the icons
themselves
[Music]
um but icons are not just about battle
in Final Fantasy 16 we deeply explore
the backgrounds of each one and we find
that their faith uh very greatly based
on where they reside some are revered as
Heroes While others are forced to fight
and are treated as slaves
again one of our Central points of our
narratives is going to be learning what
drives these dominance what are their
aspirations and what are their desires
why are they fighting and what are they
fighting for
all right now let's take a quick look at
our main protagonist Clive rossfield hey
Google
and so um our story in Final Fantasy 16
follows Clive Roswell through three
important stages of his life as you can
see here from the left
um his teens his 20s and his 30s is
by experiencing firsthand these events
that shape and mold Clive we can better
understand the player can better
understand what it is that motivates him
and why he eventually becomes the person
that he does
our story starts um with Clive obsessed
in his pursuit of Revenge for the loss
of his brother
um but across this journey that will
slowly change
um through chance encounters that
ultimately opened his eyes to a whole
different world
you must
but Clive is not alone in his journey
and is accompanied by his faithful Hound
torgel who in addition to being soft and
lovable and such a good good boy is
fiercely loyal and a deadly fight he's a
good boy such a good boy
so yes the story is not only about Clive
but it's a torgle's story as well
all right and finally let's talk a
little bit more about our twin-tiered
battle system that I mentioned before
foreign
combat can be split up into two
different types the first being player
versus enemy battles in which Clive
himself fights against creatures using a
customizable combination of unique and
Powerful iconic abilities acquired from
the different icons he meets along his
journey
many many different abilities can be
learned and upgraded and customized in a
way that's going to match each player's
play style
and our second type of battle are the
icon versus icon battles in which Clive
himself becomes an icon to clash with
other icons
is
these unique massive scale encounters
are all created um from the ground up to
have this unique feel to each of them
that it's not going to be the same every
time
okay so next up um we have a video
that's going to showcase the first type
of battle the one that showcases Clive's
iconic abilities as for the iconic
clashes we have another video for later
uh in the presentation so let's watch
this first one on iconic abilities
[Music]
oh
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
a combinations
all right and again what you saw in this
video is only a fraction of the
different type of uh combinations that
are available
um and uh achievable through our unique
system and so we hope to release more of
that information in the near future